so did you guys see what Trump spokesman
said on CNN yesterday oh my god this was
unbelievable
I thought I had seen it all in there and
they're like non answering of questions
right
Oh
have a seat what I miss you are you miss
this what's going on oh it's uh you know
it's the last show I'm trying to the
last show oh my god what did you piss
off peter thiel what happened exact that
he is his his revenge no no bounds
no it knows no bounds it knows no bounds
no uh I just I just decided to stop by
okay and tell you I love you oh and I
and may I say something else if I may
sure you have a moment no you mean take
the moment thank you
uh Jon Stewart everyone yeah oh I have
been in situations in what we call show
business television where they have my
name has been on the show yeah and
they've what he called they're locked
the door and and told me to this was a
paramount executive get you get out and
a very wise man said to me
uh do not confuse cancellation with
failure and I took that so I will say
this what you my friend were tasked to
do you have done and done beautifully
you
gay voice you gave voice to to
underserved voices in the media arena
and you did it it was a show that was
raw and poignant and funny and smart you
did it from scratch and what you and
Rory and Robin and your tremendous
collaborators and Dre in the booth and
you took something and got better every
day I think that we talked about a
little thing called I guess the word
someone uses resonance did you resonate
with an audience I would say not not
only that but an important way but in a
way that you don't even realize yet and
won't reveal itself for years to come
and it's this you started a conversation
that was not on television when you
began and you worked with a group of
people who you invited to that
conversation to collaborate with you to
sharpen that conversation and what you
don't realize is you walk out of this
room and that conversation doesn't end
and all the people that you work with
are going to take what they learned here
and what they learn from you and the
beautiful experience that they had and
you're going to start to see them doing
things in the business as well and
taking that and taking other experiences
and you're gonna watch that flourish and
that's going to have you on it well
thank you so much and that's a beautiful
and so in closing yes I want to say to
you this you did it but no you did it
no you're my date no you can't I can't
see the land that way oh man thank you I
love you for being with us thank you
Oh
you